ja also das ist jetzt
da fehlen mir fast die worte wenn es um
das thema gerhard schröder geht also
wenn man sich die letzten 24 48 stunden
anschaut von gerhard schröder der einer
der besten partys von wladimir putin ist
dann muss man sich doch wirklich an die
nase fassen und die augen drei mal
reimen und fragen was ist eigentlich mit
dem ehemaligen bundeskanzler
los hat er überhaupt nicht begriffen auf
wessen payroll er dasteht als mitglied
des aufsichtsrats des staatskonzerns
rosneft also quasi eines konzerns der
putin untersteht gerhard schröder hat
erneut heute die aufforderung aus seiner
partei bekommen endlich seine mandate im
namen des russischen staates zurück zu
geben er ist heute von zwei firmen
sozusagen vor die tür gesetzt worden als
berater er hat mehrere appelle aus der
eigenen partei bekommen der ehemalige
bundeskanzler österreichs
kern ist schon vor wenigen tagen aus dem
aufsichtsrat der russischen staatsbahn
zurückgetreten beispielsweise weil er
sagt mit dem system mit dem regime von
balda putin will ich nichts mehr zu tun
zu haben einzig gerhard schröder hält
wladimir putin noch die stange das ist
beschämend für deutschland dass es
beschämend für das ansehen unseres
landes gerhard schröder war unser
bundeskanzler und mein einziger pellis
wenn er so an martina putin festhält
lieber gerhard schröder dann gehen sie
doch nach moskau westen mit einem
business class ticket
mit einem business class ticket nach
moskau was sagst du dazu
genau richtig genau dass er sollte
verdammt noch mal in moskau wohnen wenn
er so eine politik werde ich finde es
beschämend ich hab mal gerhard schröder
als ich jünger war und angefangen habe
politik nicht zu interessieren wirklich
bewundert wie er da durchgegangen ist
bei der agenda 2010 wird ein kanzler
wurde wir wir als kanzler dort
vorgegangen ist aber was mit diesem mann
los ist ich kann es nicht verstehen wie
man sich bilder anschauen kann wie in
diesen minuten hier in hier in kharkiv
mit den waffen von wladimir putin
menschen getötet werden zivilisten
getötet werden und er dafür sorgt
gesorgt hat in den vergangenen jahren
dass diese waffen erst bezahlt werden
konnten durch seine gas lobbyismus dass
er sich spätestens jetzt sagt ich habe
mein vater im krieg verloren gerhard
schröders aufgewachsen mit einer allein
erziehenden mutter er muss doch wissen
was krieg bedeutet wie viele menschen
dort sterben wie kann er weiter an der
seite von wladimir putin stehen es geht
nicht in meinen kopf ich weiß nicht was
bei gerhard schröder los ist auch seine
alten spd freunde scheinen das nicht zu
wissen da sind ja heute selbst seine
engsten vertrauten aus diesem kreis
rausgegangen nur eines weiß ich ganz
sicher ich als steuerzahler will nicht
mehr länger nur noch einen fällig für
diesen mann bezahlen der verdammt noch
mal mit wladimir putin ins bett geht der
soll gefälligst keine sicherheit mehr
haben der soll kein auto mehr haben der
soll keinen cent vom deutschen staat
bekommen und ich will dass die deutsche
politik etwas tut und dass die spd in
rausschmeißt und dass er dann am besten
das ticket nach russland nimmt
paul das ist auch vollkommen richtig
gesagt und ganz interessant ist ja das
ist auch gerhard schröder war der anfang
des jahrtausends kein krieg gesagt hat
der nämlich george bush den finger
gesteckt hat und gesagt hat was man auch
nicht mit mir wir sind eine
friedensmacht sie haben es gerade schon
gesagt herr bosbach ich will keinen
krieg und ausgerechnet gerhard schröder
steht jetzt auf der seite des jähnigen
der ein krieg angezettelt hat einen ganz
ganz blutigen ganz hinterhältigen fiesen
wirklich unverschämten krieg der uns
alle fassungslos macht das ist mit
normalen worten glaub ich nicht mehr zu
erklären und es ist jahrelang erzählt
wurden gut dass wir gerhard schröder
haben die hat einen kurzen draht zu den
gegner kann einfluss nehmen so als wenn
gerhard schröder putin davon abhalten
würde andere länder zu überfahren das
ist irre überhaupt natürlich ist es
wichtig wir werden irgendwann wird der
krieg vorbei sein dann brauchen wir
wieder gute beziehungen gesprächsebene
zu russland aber putin ist ein
kriegsverbrecher des noch nie von rainer
demokrat gewissen ist ein lupenreiner
despot gewesen und all das was die
ehemaligen regierungschefs wurde ihm
eine bundespräsidentin an
annehmlichkeiten haben personal
fahrersicherheit büro haben sie doch
weil sie nach wirkende verpflichtungen
haben im interesse der bundesrepublik
deutschland der muss gerhard schröder
sich entscheiden will er für die
bundesrepublik deutschland in ihrem
interesse in der welt werben oder stellt
er sich für viel geld in die dienste von
putin er hat ja abholen auch kein büro
mehr sein büroleiter auf wie sich aber
wieder mehr anstand als galerie ihre
mitarbeiter mehr anstand als der chef
rechtlich dürfte es schwierig sein aber
ich glaube wenn der deutsche bundestag
in einer resolution gerhard schröder
auffordern würde auf all das zu
verzichten dole und er eindeutig oder
sich zu entscheiden putin oder wir das
hätte schon wirkung
einigkeit bislang in der runde begeben
sich auch noch zu ihnen herr auf leise
gerhard schröder alles genommen werden
was er vom deutschen staat finanziert
bekommt ich muss mich auch mal 1 3 v.re
seien anschließend ich bin auch komplett
dafür ja der druck und der juristische
weg wurde er gerade von einem rosbach
aufgezeigt muss schon erhöht werden
insbesondere auch weil das dem ansehen
deutscher politik schadet ich schaue
auch häufig aus dem osten herauf auf
unsere politik war ja auch selbst hier
in deutschland abgeordneter und das ist
etwas was man uns immer beneidet hat
dass die politiker eben auch wenn es
hier in deutschland häufig anders
gesehen wird ist die politiker eben
nicht sich einfach nur die taschen voll
machen wollen dass die politiker eben
für die sache für das land und für das
gemeinwesen einstehen und mit einem
solchen beispiel das also ein ex kanzler
sich für das geld interessiert und für
nichts anderes machen wir auch unser
renommee in der welt kaputt das ist für
mich der hauptgrund gute beziehung zu
russland wären für mich nicht der grund
zu sagen dass man jetzt jeden der gute
beziehung jemals zu russland hatte oder
hat verurteilen und so weiter soll wir
alle die das zuhause haben ja ich habe
nämlich auch ganz zu hause wir machen ja
das geschäft mit russland möglich nicht
die manager die da oben sitzen dann
würde ich schon immer differenzieren
aber eine ein eindruck von
bestechlichkeit sollte ein
ex-bundeskanzler
eben nicht hinterher den hinterlässt er
jetzt gerade aber ehrbare wir sind ja
nicht die einzigen 5 in deutschland die
so empfinden also auf twitter wird der
ruf ja auch immer immer stärker ist es
denn im bereich des möglichen was muss
denn jetzt passiert damit wirklich mal
gesagt hat so er schröder jetzt reicht's
ich glaube es gilt über seine
heimatstadt hannover wenn ich es richtig
im kopf habe hat man sich nicht dazu
durchringen können ihm die
ehrenbürgerwürde abzuerkennen und dann
muss der deutsche bundestag diesen
politischen druck aus ihm rechtlich wird
es wohl nicht gehen da gilt eben
gleiches recht für alle und das ist ja
nicht verboten also rechtlich verboten
sich in die dienste jedenfalls mittelbar
eines despoten zu stellen aber ich
glaube wenn gerhard schröder erfahren
würde es sind allen fraktionen der
deutschen bundestag die mich nicht mehr
in dieser funktion haben wollen wenn er
privat mit putin befreundet sein will
ist es für mich schlimm genug man macht
keine gemeinsame sache mit einem
kriegsverbrecher das ist aber ein
anderes kapitel als wenn jemand sagt ich
weiß ist das dürfte ein paar
hunderttausend euro steuer kosten im
jahr kosten was ist das 407.000 wir
wissen es besser 407.000 muss der
deutsche steuerzahler bezahlen damit
gerhard schröder hier seine
annehmlichkeiten hat ein mann der bis
zur stunde sich weil gott diesen krieg
einen verbrecherischen angriffskrieg zu
nennen manuela schwesig kriegt ja gerade
die kurve in mecklenburg vorpommern hat
gemerkt ist auf völlig falschem weg und
ist umgedreht
stunde nicht da würde ich gerne einmal
ein paar weitergeben sagt manuela
schwesig kriegt gerade die kurve würdest
du das auch so einschätzen
besser spät als nie wobei ich glaube da
hat der ukrainische botschaft natürlich
das recht dass er das als zynisch
betrachtet wenn manuela schwesig jetzt
ihren landtag war es glaube ich in den
ukrainischen nationalfarben zeigt
nachdem sie alles dafür getan hat die
ukraine mit zu destabilisieren nämlich
dadurch dass sie für nord stream zwei so
gekämpft hat also man wundert sich schon
ein bisschen wer plötzlich alles auf der
seite der ukraine steht und das
eigentlich schon immer so gesehen hat
und so weiter und so fort also da sind
ganz viele trittbrettfahrer unterwegs
aber wir müssen ja die situation so
nehmen wie sie jetzt ist
es ist besser dass politiker verstehen
was ich für fehler getan habe es wäre
schön wenn sie das auch mal klar
benennen würden und nicht einfach sagen
wir haben uns irgendwie geehrt nein ist
zum ihren gehört auch dazu dass man sich
täuschen lässt dass man für bestimmte
fakten offenbar nicht erreichbar ist wie
einzelne politiker ist waren aber
dennoch als jemand der jetzt in der
ukraine sitzt kann ich nur sagen gut so
und das kommt er auch hier in der
ukraine an die demonstrationen die
500.000 oder die hunderttausenden die da
unterwegs waren die klaren statements
der politik die gute rede von olaf
scholz das wirkt schon persönlich wobei
natürlich die menschen hier gerade ganz
andere sorgen haben als was deutschland
über sie denkt